では
慈悲の瞑想いたします
私は
幸せでありますように
私の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の
[音楽]
願い事が
叶えられますように
私に
悟りの光が
現れますように
私は
[音楽]
幸せでありますように
私は
幸せでありますよう
幸せであります
ようにこれから私は
幸せでありますようにと心の中で
繰り返し
念じてください
私の
親しい生命
が
幸せでありますよう
私の親しい
生命の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の
親しい
生命の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私の
親しい
生命にも
悟りの
怒りが
現れますよう
私の親しい
生命が
幸せでありますように
私の親しい
ねが
幸せでありますように
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せであります
ように
はいこれから親しい生命が
幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し
念じます
続けるものが
幸せでありますように
息苦しい行けるものの
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
行けるものの
願い事が
叶えられますように
行けるものにも
悟りの光が
現れますように
生きていけるものが
幸せでありますように
等しい行けるものが
[音楽]
息苦しい行けるものが
幸せであります
これから生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し心の中で
念じます
私の
嫌いな生命が
幸せでありますように
私の
嫌いな生命の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の
嫌いな
願い事が
叶えられますように
私の
嫌いな生命にも
悟りの光が
現れますように
私を
嫌って寝る生命が
幸せでありますように
私は
嫌いの手にいる生命の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私を
嫌ってみる
生命の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私は
嫌いなんて言える生命
にも悟りの光が
現れますよう
に生きていけるものが
幸せでありますように
行けるものが
幸せでありますよう
に
等しい行けるものが
幸せであります
[音楽]
終わりますありがとうございます
では
義理の瞑想いたします
私は
幸せでありますように
私の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますよう
に私の
[音楽]
願い事が
叶えられますように
[音楽]
私に
悟りの光が
現れますように
[音楽]
では
慈悲の瞑想
よろしいですか
それでは合唱してください
と
荒波と様3分ださー
ばば川と
荒浜
[音楽]
サラマンガッチャーミング
セレナンガチャミンドテヤンキーダマン
サラマンガッチャーミルディアン
セレナガチャミンドテテヤンキー
[音楽]
皿なんか
チャーム
[音楽]
ガチャ見てやん
ピーターマンガッチェンビ
それなんか
チャーム
p3がん
サラナンガチャミマにしかパドン様
に
セカパパダン
サマリアマにしかパドゥンサマーディア
アディナダナーエーラマに
せっかくサマリア
噛みすみちゃあちゃら
に
近場でサマー
ディアミー
試す
ミチャーチャーラエラマに
せっかく
サマリア
上山に
チェッカーパダン
[音楽]
サマリアママだった
にしかた
がサマーディア
ツラメラヤマンジャパマーだったなえらま
に
セカオパパダン様
これから
します
ご一緒に唱えてください
私は
幸せ
であります
ように
私の
[音楽]
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますね
私の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私に
悟りの光が
現れますように
私は
あります
幸せであります
[音楽]
私は幸せでありますようにと繰り返し
念じます
私
の
親しい
生命が
幸せ
でありますように
私の
親しい
生命の
[音楽]
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私
の親しい
生命の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私の
親しい
生命にも
悟りの光が
現れます
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せであります
ように
[音楽]
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せであります
ように
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せにありますよう
に親しい生命が幸せでありますようにと
繰り返しになります
生きとしてるものが
[音楽]
幸せ
でありますように
生きとしけるものの
悩む
苦しみが
なくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの
願い事が
叶えられますように
生きとしてるものにも
悟りの光が
現れますように
生きとしけるものが
幸せでありますように
息苦しい
けるものが
幸せであります
ように
生きていけるものが
[音楽]
幸せであります
生きとしきるものが幸せでありますように
と繰り返しになります
生きる
ものが
幸せでありますように
生きていけるものが
生きる
ものが
幸せでありますよう
にはいありがとうございます
はい今日の
講演会の
会場日の
名前まで出ていると思いました今朝は
ね
純一様
[音楽]
震盪
高久様
前で真理子様
以上ですか
そういう
5人の方々の
放送で放送によって今日の講演会の実現
できる
できるようになりました
幸福でありますように心が明らかになり
ますよう
に健康でありますように
達することができますようにと
誓願いたします
そういうことで
あります
今日のテーマは
この判断力がある正しい
[音楽]
判断
2回が入ってますね
絵の道のりということで
これ話に入る前に
この
判断
判決ということは
ものすごい難しいんです
日常でも我々は
判断していますけど
まぁほとんど間違ってます
よ
極限に間違ってないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりもうちょっといい判断があったん
じゃないかなと
これ2+2=という感じの
判断はできません
そこで私は
23ヶ月前から悩んだ本がありまして
大体の忘れちゃったんだけどね
その本でこの
すごくの判断することを助かっていてね
色んなデータを取って取って
載せられれば現代社会はね判断決断
外主ですからねそれですごいマンモス会社
などとかね
などがいてねそういう人々は正しい
判断しないと
もうすごい
[音楽]
億単位で超単位で金がなくなってしまっ
たりするしマンモス会社であっても倒産し
てしまう可能性もあるしたくさんの人々が
おかしすぎるなるそれもあるし
あれはちょっと
判断間違ったところで
相手にすごい
損害賠償を払わなくちゃいけなくなっ
ちゃうしまぁそういうこと
起こるんだからねまあこれアメリカの情報
書いた本でしたけどねだからすごい真剣に
どういう風に判断するのかということは
あらゆる側面でしたりしてやったことで
このたくさん
科学者たち研究者たちがいろんな社会学
心理学それから
路地いろんな
立場から
調べてみてそれはいいんだけど私は
ちょっと面白い
覚えているデータがセクションがあって
この
裁判の判断いくつか例に出してあって彼ら
がデータ取ったのは
アメリカへこの
レジデンスアメリカに住むための教科
欲しいという風に
裁判に出す文章なんですね
で結構あちらこちらからメキシコから
いろんなところから開いてきて
提案出すんですね裁判
でOKと言ったら
取れるん
ですダメと言っちゃうともう帰らなくちゃ
いけない
[音楽]
そこで
まぁこういうこういう条件揃っているなら
ば
在留資格ある
という風にはっきり
項目決まっているん
ですなのに
判決はすごくいい加減だと
面白いことは朝始めた時
結構
許可OKになる気がする
ケースが多いんだそうですそれで11時半
で12時になってくるとほとんど
何やこれと
いつでもそういう傾向この人
昼ご飯食べる時間になってくるとなんか
腹が早くご飯食べたいという感じで
あれ何も調べないでもう結果
ということになるんだ
とだから
冗談で書いて
まぁもしあなた方には
ラッキーだったらあなた方のケースは朝
早く受け取ったらあなたはラッキーだよ
ということは法律的な判断だからしっかり
しなくちゃあかんでしょうそれはしっかり
していないん
ですそこで
裁判経営者我々の分かりやすいんだから他
のケースたくさんあったんだけどね
例えばこの
罪を犯したならば
1年から
5年までの
なっていますか
インプレッションの
刑務所に入れちゃいますよ
あれは
線から
1万か20万までの道路の罰金とかねある
場合は
一応有罪だとなるんですね
それでどうやって
バッケンバッツ決めるのかと
この人
刑務所に入れるか入れないかと
入れるならば一か月間から2年までだ
からだから裁判官は1ヶ月と言ったらいい
ですで1年と言ったら1年で
これ判断できますか
ね日本で法律で何か
読んだんだけど
空港でねここからここまで
罰金だよと
未満から20万間のこれを法律を犯したら
罰金とだからどうやって
裁判官がねただその法律を犯したと
ぴったし照明立証できてもどうやって罰金
決めるんですか
なぜ法律を作る場合は
ねそんなにこれからこれまでといい加減に
設定するんですか
そういうことでたとえ客観的にデータ
調べるという
裁判システムにしたっても
判決は
ただの9時だと
明るかってない
かそんな感じなもんやと
だから
我々には世界でみんな正しく判断して
くれるという
これあれは
専門的に
判断する組織なんです
法律システムというの
警察もそうでしょう
警察も
現場でそれなりに判断しなくちゃいけない
結構
警察
官は現場で決めて
判断して
終了ということは結構あります
そこでその上のケースはもっと上の方に
裁判とかに回すんでしょう
だから
警察に浸っても
判断が曖昧ですよ
私学生
があってこのその時誰かえらい誰かが
アメリカの大統領か誰かわからんだけどね
来る予定で
東京の間でこのすごい警備厳しい
それで私の友達がいてその人のその一番
[音楽]
もう
補給のプラスの人々住んでいるところに家
買って住んでいるんですねだからそっちを
行ってご飯食べたり遊んで帰ったりして
これで何か私なんかレポートが何かあった
と思ったけどそれで
友達と一緒にじゃあ終わったんだから帰り
ましょうと
言って帰る時は
何か道がよく分からなくて
どこかでちょっと
信号無視か何とか知ってしまったんです
しかし夜なんですすごく夜です
警備厳しい
セキュリティ厳しいところでいきなり飛ん
できて車
停めて
いきなりあなた方は
信号無視しちゃってとかねすごい向こうは
怪しいと思ったでしょうね
たら運転する人にそれって別に見たら車
なんかみんな外人だけで
ね
同じケースよりこういうところに行きたい
んだけど
ここで行けばいいんですか右ですか左です
かとかね
道を聞いた
聞いちゃうとこの人はこれはね
[音楽]
行きましょうと言ってあのね信号で
ちゃんと止めてくださいよとそれで終わり
あれで止めて何か勉強していろいろ
罰金つけなくちゃあかんですよ
明確に犯罪だから
ね
我々すごくマジック困っていたしそれ聞い
ちゃうと向こうは
仕事だから
ねそれ教えると
忘れてしまっちゃって
変えて消していってくださいと言われ
ちゃったんだからね
だから私の車運転私に乗っていた車は運転
席とか
辛いことやったのか
あるいは本気で道を知らなくて聞いたのか
わからないし私は知ったのは
警察
官が相当
混乱して
法律を犯しているのにそれ調べることは
ミスったんです
ですから人間だからそういうこと
よくあり得る
ですから
これ大変なテーマなんです
じゃあ話に入ります
だいたいテーマはこういうテーマに
合わせてしゃべろうと思ってます最初に
命のスキン
尊厳自由というテーマ自由にならない何で
したっけ見えない
認識
それから4つの機器と言ってもらってそれ
から
観察で
判断を超えるセクションが2つありました
けどこれ場所がないんだからその程度にし
たんですねこういう
項目で進んでいます
1番目これ命の仕組み
でこれから
仏教なのでしょうちょっと難しくなります
からね
で生きるとは行為です
これ
覚えておいてください
いくら私の話聞いたってもほとんどみんな
何の成長もないの真面目に話が聞いてない
この1行だけでも皆様の人生に
大いに役に立ちします
これシンプルに言葉に
並べたことじゃないん
こいつはあんまり難しい日本語を知らんだ
から言えないシンプルな日本語の言葉
まとめているんでそうじゃないんです
極限にシンプルですけど真理です
それは事実真理に語るときのポイントでも
あります言っていることはややこしくて
分からないんだったら言っている人は
分かってないんです何言ってるのか
あれは真理ではなくて
曖昧中途半端な概念なんです
明確に
シンプルな言葉で語るものははっきりした
心理
ですだから生きることは恋です
それを覚えておいてくださいいつでも誰か
が何で生きると
怖いです何か行為するんです
この人は何ですかと言うと考えること話す
こと
身体を動かすこと
あまりも心配
この未遂が何かやっている
私は違いますよと
私はの行為は4番5678ぐらいやります
よとあるわけないでしょう
だから真理に
従って真理に戻って真理に基づいて生きて
みてくださいよ超心配できてられますよ
生きることは好意ですこういうメッセージ
ですそれで失敗するならばそれで足かせで
いろんな
罠にはめるならば
かわいそうこのアホらしい
騙されたあれになったこうなったとか
かわいそうでしょう
だからしっかり生きる人は
物凄い明確にシンプルなんです
考えることを喋ることと身体を動かすこと
ぐらいはちょっと気をつけることできる
でしょうに
この大げさな
宇宙のロケットサイズじゃないでしょう
それは専門用語と言えば
時間も間のという行為ですね
はい次もうちょっと
好意について勉強しましょう
行為っていうのはファンクションですね
こう言っていうのは
ストップしないん
ですずっと流れているん
です行為は止まったということはないん
ですこの身体の中の
止まったらこの物体がもう死んじゃったん
です
だから一秒も行為は
止まりません
ですからこの生きることを全て分かりたい
理解したいと言ったら
絶えず流れる3種類の行為です
例えば寝ている
でも身体が動いているでしょう
止まらないん
です心臓でも休んだらどうなるじゃあ俺は
ちょっと休んで
終わりですね
身体の中に我々の消化
器官やら全て
止まりません
脳は自分の仕事
ずっとやっているんです寝ていてもやって
いるん
です今そうやっているんだけど
身体の中は
自分に与えられた行為はずっとやっている
ん
休みがないん
ですだから人間無知で真理知らない物凄い
原始的いくら価格学んだっても
原始人は原始人です
猿にちょっと金のネット好きだと猿は
すごいお嬢様になりますかねなるわけない
でしょう
ダイヤもついているかもしれません
抜けないんですだから人間社会ではこの
休みあれやこれやとかね色んな言葉がある
でしょう
だからみんな
休む時ハチャメチャなことを
する問題を起こす
だから仕事を休んでと言ったっても行為が
変わっただけなんです
それは面白いことは自然界物質世界宇宙も
すーっと変化しているんですずっと変わっ
ているん
です
止まること
瞬間たりともないん
です皆様は知っているかどうか分からない
んだけど
太陽がちょっと休んだとか
ある
地球はちょっと休んだとか
この
絶えず変化するこの行為が
存在なんですこれは私生命体だけに限って
ない物質も同じことです
ずっと変わって変わって変わってこう
変わって変わっていかないと物質として
成り立たないん
です太陽が地球が
惑星がもう何でも銀河系でも何でもいいん
です学校法でも割とでもアイドルまで発見
してないんだけどただ観念的に考えるだけ
で
止まってないん
ですそこで生命になってくると
判断ということは出てくるん
です物質には判断要らない
決まった法則によって流ればいいん
ですそれで物質と生命の
違うところはっきりわかります生命の身体
も物質ですからもうどうしてもどうしよう
もない変化があります
終えることなどなどね心臓でやら臓器が
動いておれば細胞が動いていることそれは
できないんですねそれはもう自分に決まっ
たスピードで変化してい
しかし
判断して行為するというところもあります
ねそれは心の感覚
だから科学世界では心というものはないん
です
ヨーロッパで
心理学というものもあるんだけど
でも心ということは
未だにわかっていないん
ですまぁ色々連中がね色んなものを始めて
それ開発発展されて今の現代の心理学と
いうことあるんだけど
心っていうものはまだ分かってないん
ですこれ無視できんだからこの言葉
ちょこちょこありますよマインドとかね
あるんだけどねそれって何でしょうかと
聞いちゃうと分からない
だから生きている生命体には心があります
だから生命と言うん
心が入っちゃうとちょっと
違うことを見えるんです
判断して行為するということも
あるん
ですそれで生命っていうのは
判断しようかしないかただ
宇宙法則で流れる変化もある行為もある
それに
達して
判断して行う
行為もある例えば私に
喋ることも
黙っている
黙っていることもできます
そこで
失敗するん
です自分が判断する地球は自転する
判断する必要ないんです法則に乗っ取って
ずっと自転しているんです
判断要らない
我々老いることあんなにいらないそれは
ちゃんと時間と一緒に
物質の
組み合わせている物質が
退化していきます
それに判断に入れません
しかし
判断してやるものはありますね
私たちはこの
判断要らないものはあまり
管理できないんだから
放っておく
管轄外
地球自転することは
それ別に不思議でも何でもなくそろそろ
冬になるんだから
明るい時間が短くなっちゃうし黒くなる夜
が長くなるし
驚かない
ねそれはもうずっと言っての法則で動いて
いるんだから
驚く必要はない
知った方が
便利それだけ
しかし
判断して考える
判断して喋る
判断して身体を動かす
そこでそれはいい加減な判断だったら考え
たことはいい加減なものになる
喋ったことはいい加減なものになる
身体いい加減動かしたことになるいい加減
だったら結果も
いい加減な
好ましくない結果にはなる
ですから判断が間違いであり中途半端で無
批判的であるならば生きることは
堕落を目指してしまいます
当たり前のことですよ進化向上
幸福
成功を目指すならば正しい
判断することです
だから
これはどんな生命にも同じ法則ですけど
動物に説法できんだからね我々人間の間で
これは何とか考えて下着して研究して何と
かすることはできますねだから
我々の人間には自分が判断して行動して
いるということは分かるしそこで正しい
判断しましょうと自分の子供に食べる時で
も
正しい
判断から出た言葉でなければ
悪い結果になる
自分が自分勝手で判断で考えるんだけど
判断が間違っているならば思考によって人
が大変危険な
ものに変わってしまいます
だから世にある全ての精神的な病気という
ものは
思考の問題
です考えてはいけないもの
科学的でないもの客観的でないもの
データに
基づかないものいわゆる妄想ですね
考えて
病気になって人生はダメになるんです
だから西洋的にいろいろカウンセラーにし
たり薬をあげたりするんだけどそれで
治らない
冬ははっきりと
このポイントに行ってないん
ですjustmanということに当たって
ないん
です誰もこの自分が考えてなんとなく考え
たということでしょうこれは自分が
ジャッジメントして考えているという風
に発見しない
そういうわけで
論理的な立場ですけど
判断が間違っちゃうと最悪
正しい判断だったら人生はOK心配なしな
んです
はい次に進んでみましょうか
はいそこで私はこの
尊厳自由という人間使っている単語
みんな
偉そうに真面目にそういう単語を使って
ますけど
あんまり内容は考えてないんですね
尊厳大事やと言いながら尊厳を壊す
自由と言いながらずーっと人の自由を奪っ
ている
私たちは毎日頑張ってます
よ友達作っちゃえばね異性の友達相手を
束縛されることしか考えてないん
ですでも人は自由だよと全く正反対のこと
やるん
私の子供は自由に育てたいと言いながら
完璧に管理して
字を奪っちゃうん
ですそういう人間ですからね何歌ったって
も問題はそのまま
悪化するだけ
判断の責任はその個人にあります
判断するのが個人です
そこで判断するために
時々知識使うし知識っていうのは外から来
たもので
で指導誰かにの指導で
判断する場合もあるし
提案
影響なども
ありますが
判断は自分でするん
ですこれであまりレベル低くなるんだから
書いてないんだけど
例えば
自分を脅して
ブラックメールして
これこれやりなさい
よ
違法なことを
犯罪のことやりなさい
と言っちゃうと犯罪のことやるとし
ましょうそうすると
弁解しますね私はこういう風に
ブラックペンされていた
脅されていた
まあ子供やら家族
にすごい危険なことすると
脅していた
だから私はもう
仕方がなくこれやりましたから無罪だと
言っても
いくら
脅しがあってもやると決めてない自分
でしょう
責められて責められてやったとでもやると
決めたの自分なんです
周りの影響で強引な
プレッシャーによってね自分の気持ちと
逆らう
判断になる場合であっても
判断はこの
責任です
個人には
他人には生きることができない
この感覚
です判断することは他人にいじることは
できません他人がギャーギャーギャー
喋って脅していろんなことするんだけど
自分が判断する
これやらなかったら殺してやるぞ
とやりませんよと言ったらどう
でしょう
殺してくださいやりませんよ
と例えば自分を脅してやらなかったら
殺そうということはこの
脅している人々の役に立つことでしょう
それは自分でやらないで誰か弱い人を
捕まってやらせてもらう
と
汚いやり取りでしょう
殺してくださいやりません
行っちゃうとこの脅してる人々また新しい
判断しなくちゃいかんです
殺すか
殺しちゃうとこいつはこれやってくれない
そうすると我々は損する
いやですから殺してやると
殺しちゃったらそこで別な問題を受けて
その人々にとってはとかねだからそんなに
大げさなことじゃない
殺そうと脅されても
という判断すればどうですかとか
人間それやらないだけで
やってみたら
理解不可能なものすごい面白いこと起こる
んです
だいたい悪いことをしないと判断すると
必ず良い結果になるん
です良いことなら
殺してもやるぞと殺されてもやるぞという
態度OKですよこれ仏教のいっぱい
物語れるんでしょうその物語の中で自分の
命がなくなっても良いことならやりますと
いう
態度いろんなストーリーの中に書いている
ん
ストーリーだからお釈迦様の教えを明確に
するために
作ったストーリーですよじゃあ叩く物語と
かありますけど結構たくさんありますもの
ばかり
は私はあまり私の
説法では物語使いませんだけどね
まあだからしょうがないんだけど結構ある
ことはあるん
です良いことなら
いくら自分の命に危険があってもやるなぜ
なら行為は良いことです
それによって
大変良い結果になるん
ですそういうわけで
判断することだけ
他人に生きることはできません
なんか選挙で投票するような感じです
よ実験でいろんなこと言われて言われて
言われてね
これとか頭もうハチャメチャ
混乱しちゃって
だからと言って
私に
投票しなさいと言えますけど
投票するかしないか
その人を判断するそれは
投票の場合ものすごく分かります
ねあれ
自分の国だったらちょっと
迷惑かけるだけ日本だったら名前書くん
ですかねどちらそれ誰か見張って何でこの
人の人の名前書きなさいとこれできない
でしょう
これは内緒で自分の
徹底した
プライバシーで書いて
畳んで
箱に入れる
それは自分の判断
その瞬間だけ自由が働くん
です
世の中ではこの法則をだからこの
世の中この
判断の問題だと分かってないんですだから
全ての生命は自分で判断してやっているん
です例えば安いの動物だって餌
あげたら餌撒いてあげてもその動物はお腹
が空いてんだからとにかく食べる
分かりません
よやべえ
てくれるわけない
そんな
甘くないよあとが思って握る場合もあり
ます
だから世の中でこの自由尊厳と言っている
のはまぁそんなあたりですよ
しかし生命に自由はなく
束縛されて生きているというのは
仏教の考え
です仏教全く反対のこと言うんです
生命に自由がないんだよ
人間だけじゃないん
です
束縛されています
よ例えばお腹が空いて餌もない野生の
命があって
かわいそうだからこっちいっぱい余って
いるんだからじゃあ餌
撒いてあげましょうと言っても
そこで食いたくて食いたくても
仕方がないという風な感情があったら来て
パクパク食べちゃって
突っ込まれちゃって
殺される可能性もありますねその
あるいはこの野生動物はものすごく人間の
こと怖くて
怯えちゃって
人間の匂いするところの言ってわからん餌
は見えますけど
そこら辺人間行ったり来たりするんだから
人間の匂いがものすごく派手に感じるん
あるいはこういうものない
とだからそこは自由がないん
です
怯えがあって
震えちゃって
そこで食べないと判断したんです
とにかくお腹空いてんだから食っちゃうと
判断したんです
だからそこら辺は
判断
個人の感情が
判断を維持しちゃった
んです他人にそれできないん
です野生の動物は自分で怯えているならば
怯えが
判断決めたんです食うなよ
と食いませんと
すごく初級があって食いたい食いたいと
いう気持ちがあったらその感情が食えと
いう判断
食います食べますという判断したん
ですだから
仏教から見ると自分がないん
です自分の中に自分の
判断をいじるコントロールする
だから仏教はもっと深く行って
即世間的には人間は自由です
仏教の立場から見るそうじゃないんです
あなたにはフリーな判断できません
あらゆる条件であなたを抑えられています
よ
世間の条件は無視できますよ
心中から出てくる上で
条件どうしますか
例えばすごい優しい人がいる
いつでも周りに対して優しくしますという
風に決めて生きて
いるその人は当然すごい
病気で倒れる
ものすごい苦しい病気
その時は誰か誰か来てどうですかこれです
か聞いちゃうと私は昔からも優しくすると
決めたんだからと言ってそれできなくなり
ますよ
その時は
ですからこの自分の中から出てくる条件で
自由がなくなっているんですはい次に行っ
てみましょうか次のテーマに
はいこれから
仏教ですからこの話はね人は自由じゃない
と
いう立場で自由にならない認識
は
我々物事認識しますね生きるものは誰だっ
て物事を認識します
認識は当てにならないね犬の認識
猫の認識
クマの認識
人間の同じじゃないんですよ
認識は感覚
概念
衝動
認識は一緒に
不可分で働き置きます
認識しようとすると
3つのこといつでも揃っているんです一番
は感覚
感じるね何かを
感じたものに認識するんですだからどの
ように感じたかということによって認識
するん
です例えば誰かちょっと身体を張りで刺す
としましょう
それでちょっとふざけて
刺したんだけど
中ではちょっとさすだけで怪我しない程度
でねそれは認識しますよ
そこでこの自分が感じた程度の認識するん
ですそれから
概念
そう我々頭の中で心の中でいっぱい
概念持っているん
それ
に合わせて
認識する
例えばちょっとご飯を握って
置いておいてその上に
来た生魚の一部上に乗せている
皆様に
ご飯の上に生魚に乗せているという認識
できないん
です頼んでもできないんでしょう
自由じゃないんです
概念があるんですね
趣旨という食べ物はそれは結構
美味しい
その概念割り込んで
認識させるん
ですそれから
衝動
いつでもなんかエネルギーが何かやりたい
やりたくないとかねやりたいと思います
けどやりたくないとも同じなんです
だからそれによって
認識が変わりますだから今言ったように
ちょっと捻ったご飯の上に
飲む世界の一部を乗せている
自分がお腹も空いているそれは感覚です
概念として
寿司という概念もある
熱唱したがい
ねそうすると認識が変わります
だからお腹が
満腹の時の認識と
お腹が空いている時の認識が違います
物事を正しく認識しないで言ったって
成り立ったんですよ
この
条件3つ
レーダーさんが参加ある
感じることと
そういろんな
概念があること
それから
衝動
これ一緒に認識するんです
離れませ
んそういうことで感じることを乱れたり
感じることの場合は
暗く
て三つありましてそちらにまた強弱もあり
ますね
それによって認識が変わるん
ですそれからどんな
概念
概念膨大にありますけど
何か一部とって
認識するんだから
それから行
衝動そういうのは乱れたり
汚れたり
弱くなったり強くなったりするとそれに
合わせて
認識になります
だから私は知るということは成り立たない
ん
です何も
認識するものは
そうですかと
成り立たないん
です認識に重層魚のバイアスが入っている
んですそれでちょっと分かりやすい単語
何か認識したい正しく認識すると正しい
判断できる
正しく
認識しようと思ったのに重曹
業のバイアスが入っているん
ですそいつら認識を
左右させます
例えば勉強している誰かすぐでっかい声で
喋っちゃった腹が立つんです
誰でしょうか見たらすごいかわいい人です
怒りが消えちゃうん
ですそんなもんです
だから
認識は正しいっていうのは
ありのままに客観的に
認識することです
それは人間のところか生命にできないん
ですだから生命の認識は当てにならないん
です人間の知識は生命の自粛は当てになら
ないん
ですカラスは死んだネズミのネズミの死骸
はごちそうやと思う
認識する人間はネズミの死骸はごちそうや
と認識しない
どちらか正しいですか
ね分からん
まずどちらでも正しくないん
ですでもそれぞれみんな自分の
層で概念持っていますカラスは
これはごちそうです
食べたら
元気になります
人間がこれは危険です人間の食べるもの
じゃない
この死骸食べちゃうと
食中毒で死ぬかもしれませんとそれを全て
そう
概念
カラスも害に持っていてはいこれでどちら
正しい
本当に人間がネズミに違い見つけて食っ
ちゃったら
60度で
死ぬかもしれません
よ
そんなの何とカラス
ありえないよ
とそういうことですごい難しいことをやっ
たらありのままに
知ることが
答えなんです
これはついてないんですこのバイアスの
せいで
はい次に行きます
そこでこの
ステージ2つに分けて説明します
まあ一般世界の人々に
いくら何でも
危険性を下げましょう
きれいに消すということはできませんだ
けど例えば地震は危険ですが
被害は何とか下げることはできます
地震そのもの消すことはできない
だから私たちの認識がバイアスによって
いい加減ということはどうしようもないん
ですだったら
認識の
危険性何とか
避けましょうということでお釈迦様が
即世間の人々誰にでも仏教取ってではない
んです人間ならこの4つの
危機をチェックしてください
目を守るために謝った判断を
避けて欲しいん
です気をつけるべき4つの感情
危機があります
1ちゃんだ
ちゃんと
この
ケースで
よく使うものでこの心の
そうに入る一文なんです
一部なんですこれは
好みよく愛着などなど
何か判断すると
好みで判断しちゃう
例えば
殺到
砂糖が入っているものは好みで食べまくっ
ちゃって
豆乳になったとします糖尿病に
それでいろいろ制限されて生きているんだ
けど
突然何か自分の
好物のもの見つかっちゃう
いきなりせっかくだから
できちゃいます
好みでやられちゃったん
ですだから
仏教の人なら
昔はこれよく食べましたね私の大
好物でしたよと
いくら何で送っちゃって今までこういう
条件だからね
食べないことにするという風な判断でき
ますそうするとこの実をコントロールした
ん
ですこの裁判官の場合でも
相手が白人か黒人かということで判断が
変わるんです
男が女かということによって判断が変わる
ん
です男は何か
タレントさんみたいななんかすごい美男
だったら判断変わり
ます女がすごい美女だったらまた判断
変わります
当てにならない
よただ訴えられて女性がおばあちゃんで
ゴルフ
服を着てお風呂にも入らないんだから入ら
なかったんだからちょっと匂いもあって
外国人としていて
裁判官も
証拠あるいはここだと聞いちゃうんだけど
あまり
非国民の方見ないことにする
んですよ厳しい判断になります
ですからこの
好みということはすごい気をつけます
会社であろうが家であろうか
好みではこの
ベースとして
判断しないと2番目はどうせ怒りですね嫌
な気分
で
嫌な気分になっちゃうと
判断しましょう
お腹が空いているんだけどご飯作った人の
ことはあまり気に入らない
それとも態度も気に入らない
ご飯食べる私には結構ですと言っちゃうん
ですよ食べないと決めたんですなぜかと
この作った人が
のことはやって思ってるからなん
で3番目
まぁ
脅威
恐怖
あるいは逆に自分の弱さ
それと言うんです
直接今は脅威なんですね
怯えると
心に怯えがあっちゃう
と判断は間違え
ます4番目持ちますそれはあまり説明する
必要ないんだけど
あまりこの調べない
判断する前に
データ調べないまあいいやもうこれ行き
ますと
何でも楽チンで決めたくなるだからすごい
判断早くてえらい活発で行動する人々いる
でしょう
相当なんです
もう喋る前にもう判断して終わっているん
です
十分データが入るまでまず人のことは
みんなこの人すごく何か聞き取るん出す
ためには時間かかりますね頭が悪いんです
悪くなくてデータ足らないということで
待っているんです
自分と他人に関して大事な判断をする時
必ず気をつけるべき事実のバイアスです
この世の中でハチャメチャになっているの
はみんな知らんうちにこのバイイエスで
やられちゃうんですだから仏教の人仏教を
学んで聞いている人々の特権はこの4つ
覚えているんです
別を覚えて気をつけるん
ですたまたま失敗してもすぐあなるほど
失敗しました
この感情バイヤーでやっちゃったと
今度はやりませんという風に
するだからこのチャンネルの
暗記できるようにお釈迦様教えられている
んです
在家の人は
毎日チャンネルを
避けて
生きてみましょう
そうすると大体大体
比較的な良い判断で生きられます
だから家族であろうか仕事であろうが社会
関係であろうかどんな場合で
も自分自身の勉強であろうか
研究であろうかこの4つの感情をちょっと
抑えて制御しておいておく
表に出さないことにする
使わないことにする
それで何とか
何とかいい
判断
ベタな判断ベストの判断できませんだけど
ね
何とか待ちな判断できるようになります
そうすると何とか人生はマシになります
はい次のテーマに入ります
はいこれを4つの企業を避けるために
サポートになる
ことがあって
それは観察オプション
どうしてももう分かるでしょう正しい
判断したければ
観察しなくちゃいかんです人間観察します
外のこと
この
株価
証券買おうかなとかね外の状況だけ判断
するん
ですだからこの人間ってのすっごいいい
加減ということはこの象形の世界でよく
わかるでしょうほんのわずかな出来事で
だーっと
株が落ちたり
ほんのわさなくていきなり上がったりし
ますね
本当にバカバカしいことで
億単位で行ったり来たり損したり得したり
だからなんたらビジネスが流行ってるなと
思った途端
薬関係の
株がガーッと開け
ちゃうあもうかるちゃんだとか
そういうことで
4つの危機は避けるために
企業避けるために自分の
認識プロセスを観察する
チェックする必要が現れますだから自分
自身のこのいい加減な認識プロセスを
チェックするん
ですで二つの選択1感情の奴隷になって
判断機能を
無視して生きていますか
時々感情が出てきて感情
[音楽]
誘導にする
その場合は認識正しくない
判断は正しくないだから私は今感情でやら
れているんでしょうかチェックして
ください
今気持ち悪くて怒りでやられているだから
判断何もしないでちょっと
下げます
ちょっと休みます
あるいは欲が出てきて
作っていろんなタイプのよくあります
ね音楽聞いて
欲なんですね踊りドラマを見たいと
欲なんですね
好きなあまりにもそれ好きになっちゃうと
ね
認識が
乱れるん
です感情チェックしてより正しい判断をし
て工場の道を選びますかだからそれに
感情の
奴隷になるか
感情をちょっと抑えて判断するのかという
こと
いつでもチェックしなくちゃあかんです
4つの企業を避ける生き方であるならば
この
判断はより正しくなるのです
そういうことでこの
4つ覚えています覚えておく
仕方がないんですパーリ語だったら簡単に
覚えやすいちゃんと場合もそれだけ
覚えておいて生活する
認識するたびに
寝る時でもちょっと寝過ぎちゃうと抜く
でしょう
あれは根付かないと落ち着かない
怒りでしょう
そんな風にちょっと心の気持ちを
観察したからと言って
正しい判断は難しいん
ですはいまぁそんなところまで
即世間的な正しい判断する方法になります
ねすごいシンプル
です正しい判断できるわけないんでしょう
ここで頑張ったのは
危険を
減らすだけ
不幸を減らすだけ
はい次のテーマに行きます
続きみたいですね
具体的な人です
判断は良いか悪いか
修正できるかと行為をする前にチェック
する
だから
判断して行為を
する
判断なく行為が起きません
お医者さんが何か
悲しみみたいなもので
膝に
叩くでしょうそうすると
膝が上がっちゃうんですね
その場合は判断しようかしない関係なくて
上がるんです
流れ具合見て
身体の調子をお医者さんが決めるんですお
医者さんが人間だから判断しなくちゃいか
ん
でそうではそんなこの
ことじゃなくて
ね例えば
舞台から
落ちちゃうと
すごく痛くなる
判断じゃないねそれ
は痛くなったら
泣き叫ぶか
黙って来られるかと自分の判断なん
そういうわけで私たちは何かやりたい何か
喋りたい
と
判断するでしょう
判断しまた実行していない
実行する前にもう1回
チェックする
思ってすぐ行動に行くんじゃないん
です特にこのキャーしゃべる人々いる
でしょうすごい
綺麗な人生なんです
喋る前に
喋って行かないかね
喋りたいんですけどもうワンステップ止め
て
チェックするん
ですその時
言っていいか悪いかチェックする
これ言っちゃうとまずいと分かったら自分
が言葉を言葉の使い方いろいろ
訂正するん
です要するに行為をする前のチェックこれ
判断のチェックなんです2番目行為を行っ
ている間にも結果の戦略チェックする
決めたんだからやるじゃないん
決めたんだからやるんだけどやっている間
でこれがいいか悪いか結果が良いか悪くも
やり始めたんだから見えてきますよ
それあやっぱり悪い結果になっているん
だったらそこで中止できますということは
危険性を結構
下げることでき
ます感情になってやると決めたやって
しまったそれから後で悩んだっても意味が
ないん
です例えば感情で人を指して殺したくなっ
た
仕方がないん
ですそれでまずこれでいいかこの
判断は
チェックするといくら何でも世間では良い
と苦しみは危険だからあの人はいくら悪人
でやってもね私個人に対して悪人ですから
世間に対して悪人じゃないんだからじゃあ
やっぱりやめておこうと
殺すんじゃなくてアイスを
怒って
怒られることにするぞ
だから
怒鳴ることでも悪い結果が出ますけど
指すことよりは
危険性が少ないでしょう
にそこでもうじゃあ行動にすると言って
殺しに行くと思って
も途中でも判断した方がいいん
です
包丁を持って誘うと開けたっても
判断した方がいい
です結果悪いと言ったらどこかで中止でき
ます例えばサポートしてさせなかったそう
するそれも法律違反でしょう
だから
殺人才ではないん
です人を
落とした罪
ですかい
ますそういうわけでこの
途中でチェックすることで
危険性避けることはできます
結構
なんかすごい感情でやりたいなとかね
ボロ儲けできるんだとか欲にやられちゃう
んですねそれで
1回ぐらいちょっと
買ったりして
たくさんもっと入れた方がもっと好きか
最も儲かるんだよ入れちゃうんですそこで
先輩になっちゃい
ますやっぱりあるものを売ってしまってで
もあの他に戻さなくちゃいけないんだと
言って家も売って全部売ってまた歌詞の
やってしまうとあれは
借金しておくだけでやるというもう世界
金メダル級の愚か者たちなんです
まぁ仏教では
断然禁止ですけどなぜならばそれはどう見
たっても
科学的な合法的な収入じゃないでしょうに
それでもこの感情チェックするならば
案の定
買った相当かね
行って帰ることもできるし
100万持って行って
遊んで帰る時は
110番で10万儲かっているんだよこれ
100万持って行って
4000万円をもらいたくなっちゃう
でしょ
家も売る羽目になるん
ですだから感情いかに人の
判断をね
危険な判断にするのか
というはいそれでこういう
途中でもチェックするそれからこういう
終わるでしょう
終わったらもう結果決まっているん
ですそれで
忘れるんじゃなくてこういうこういう迫っ
こんな結果になったともうデータがあるん
です
終わったことは変わりませんだからね
だからデータとしてもうそのまま
それで
二度と同じことをやるか
決めることはできます
終わってからも結果が良かったか悪かった
かをチェックして自分の判断能力を
成長させるそれで悪かったらあんな風に
考えることはこれからやめます
良かったならばあのラインで考えることに
します
という風に
成長することでできます間違った判断を
避けるために
貪瞋痴の感情ではなく
自筆者の感情を育ててみるこれ至って簡単
便利な方法なんですこの
貪瞋痴はどうしようもなくもう
捨てられないん
命で一緒に繋がっているん
ですお釈迦様と人参町感染しなさいと言っ
てますけどこの言うのは分かりますけど
存在の仕組みでは
存在は
貪瞋痴でできているん
ですだからそれは
切断することはそう簡単ではありません
だったら何か
身の安全の方法ないのかということであの
お釈迦様は自力者という気持ちを教えたん
です
生命に対してあえて強引でもいいん
でもgck社という術の
めっちゃ明るく
慈悲の気持ちを
育ててみる
生命はみんな同じ
平等や誰だって幸せになればいいんじゃ
ない
ということは自分の命で何の命も同じ命と
してみる自分の命もゴキブリの命も同じ命
としてみる
それだったら
悪いバイエスが判断の時
働かないん
です判断する時はバイアスになるのは自費
記者な
んですこれやったら人助かるんだからやり
ますあの人あなた騙されたでしょうまぁ
そんなに私を騙したと思っているかもしれ
ませんだけど私から見ればお肉困っている
んだよ
だから助けたんだよ
という風にできます
そういうことで
俗世間では自費化粧を育てるならば
判断の
危険性がかなり
減ります
ほとんど危険性がない選考になります
はいそこで
そこで状況
上級の実践レベル
これはもう
人間皆様これやってくださいではなくて
ブッダの教えに納得している人々がやって
くださいなんです
みんなにできるわけじゃないん
ですすごい
能力が必要ですこの上級レベル
だからそれは明らかに
実践する人々のための教えで一応
理解していましょう
いたって前もおっしゃったよ教えたような
観察なんですよあの仏教は
宗教でも何でもない仏教はみんなに教えて
いるのは
観察しましょうよと
これって
研究者や科学者やみんなやっていること
でしょう
に
仏教はより完璧な観察を教えているそれ
だけ
昆虫学者は
昆虫を観察する
昆虫館させても人間工事をしないでしょう
に
微生物の学者は
微生物を観察するそれで学者にはなります
けど
人間として
成長しない
はい
仏教の場合はこの
自分を感謝しなさいと
昆虫感謝感謝したらこの中学生になるなら
ば自分を観察したら自分に対して
殺人を離れて
身体の行為
動きを
観察するこれ一番やりやすい
ある時間決めて
即世間のいろんな
殺人をやめて
身体のシンプルな働きを観察
で結構
落ちるそこで
[音楽]
最初からの言わなくちゃいけないことは
最後のラインに書いてましたけどこの場合
はこの状況実践の場合は最初から
判断
禁止なんです
例えば身体を観察すると足が痛いと感じ
ますよ
痛いと判断
ですだから
瞑想する人々は一旦見た実況して
観察するん
です判断禁止に最初から
仏教の実践ちょっと厳しいと感じるのは
この
判断なんですよ
判断してはいけないんですこれで私に聞く
こういう風にやったんでこれでいいと
言いたくなるん
です
判断消えているん
判断禁止です
いい悪いはないん
です身体の状況は
観察する
だるくなっている軽くなっている痛くなっ
ている
膨らんでいる縮んでいる
痒みがある赤い目だけは判断しているん
です
そのように身体の感覚を
体の動きをまずチェックするこれ身体には
シンプルな動きしかないんだから結構でき
ます
できちゃうともうこのレッスン終わったと
いうことになるんですいくら見たっても
身体にはこれしかないんだよ例えば私は
よく歩く瞑想を派手に
推薦していますね歩きましょう1時間が
あるこのやってください1時間1時間とか
ね1週間ぐらいやってみると相当に時間が
あるくらいしているん
ですそうすると歩く瞑想の場合はいくら
やってもこれぐらいのデータとわかるん
です
データ全部取っているん
ですそれですかそれだったらちょっと次の
ステップに進んでくださいと自動的になる
んですどういうことか
認識の中
歩く瞑想する時でも
認識が流れている
場合は上げる運ぶ運ぶそれだけでしょう
観察する
これはよく上手にできるようになってから
は
あら裏で認識も流れているんだよそれを
チェックするん
です感情の働きが
判断して
身体の行為を起こしていることを発見し
ます
認識のプロセス見てみると
認識は感情で怒りやらしてやら落ち込み
やらね色んな感情で
認識が変わるんだよと
認識してから判断するん
だあれは光の速度よりも早く起こるんです
よ
例えば
嫌な気持ちが怒りが起きた瞬間で
認識して
判断もしているん
ですそこ
で本当はねだから
認識の流れを見ると
感情がね煩悩と言いますこの修行者の場合
はね1500もありますいろんな
煩悩が
認識を
いじっていること
ありのままの認識させない
煩悩が割り込んで
判断変えるん
ですこれ見てくるんですね見えてくるん
ですね
だから
喋っても身体を動かしてもこの
[音楽]
判断
バイアスで感情
培養で
認識して判断して
身体動かしているんだということを見えて
くるんですね次に心の流れを観察します
それできたら心の流れを観察します心の
流れというのは重層凝縮を
管理していることが見えてきます
心を見てみると
十感覚と
概念と
衝動が
認識を
変えているんだ
と見えてきますよ
ただ何でこれ
瞑想として扱っているのかというとこの
認識の流れは光の速度より速いん
です我々に光の速度も
ねちょっと難しいでしょう
認識するの
だからこれ
認識
この実践法でやってみると
一秒の吐き分の一の動きはわかるんです
そこで感情が自分の
希望に合わせて
認識を変えるのであって事実をありのまま
に
認識することをさせないと発見します
感情があって煩悩があって貪瞋痴があって
怒り嫉妬憎しみなどなどがあって
認識しているん
です例えば目で何か見るときでもそれ見
なさいなんですけど
怒りで見るよくで見る落ち込みで見るあれ
感情で見るん
ですそうすると見えてないでしょう
だってこの
柱壁
怒りで見ると悪い
古いねと思っちゃい
ますよくで見るともよくできてますね
認識するんですこれかっこ悪いでもかっこ
いいでもないん
ですそれは誰も一度も認識したことがない
んです皆様この法律に初めて入ったかも
入った瞬間で感情で認識したん
ですだからこの本来いかがでしょうかと
みんなのアンケート取っちゃうと100人
は
薬の答え出すんです
答えにならないのはそれほど言語能力ない
んです
それほど単語もないんですだから
思ったことはあるんだけど
いくつかの単語しかないこれを表現する
ためにそれ使ってアンケート書くんです
よう
にだからアンケート見て我々は人々こんな
こと
成り立ってないん
です
観察作業に
判断はいらないん
です
判断しないで観察できます
一つ例出しましょう
瞑想している方々知っていると思います
けど食べる瞑想する時は
噛むかむ味わうと実況しなさいと言うん
です味わうっての味をちゃんと感じている
具体的なデータなんです
おいしいっていうのはあなたの
煩悩が決めたこと
それは間違い正しくない
美味しいとは判断
禁止だから食べる前にする人は
噛むかむかも味わうカムカム味わう
飲み込む
これ
繰り返せないとダメな繰り返して繰り返し
てやるとどんどん正しく性格にできるよう
になります
それで何か発見します
前言ったでしょう生きることは
判断して行為することをやと
瞑想終わったらいい判断しなくたってこと
ないよ
と判断しなくたってご飯食べられます
おいしいもの食いたいという先入観なかっ
た方が
楽ですよ
身体に栄養が必要ですですから
手当たり次第あるもので
栄養取ります取るかも飲み込む
すごい人生楽になります
判断はいらないことを発見するまで
頑張って欲しい
ですから
修行者は最初からも
判断しないということに
挑戦するんで挑戦するん
です
仏道では結構失敗しますそれはもう仕方が
ない
失敗しても諦めないこと
負けたという気分にならないことまた
やり直してやり直して
即席に教えた4つの機器の場合でも
完璧にできませんよ
失敗します
ちゃんと動作場合
失敗したらそれ
行ったりして
次その失敗しないことに
すればいいんです
修行中でも
私が言う通りにはいかないんです結構失敗
します
判断してしまうと
修行はすごく
暗くて嫌なことになる
判断やめちゃうと
修行ほど
心穏やかになる安穏になる安らぎを感じる
世界ないと感じるん
ですはいそういうことで判断は
禁止ですが
修行
成功した人は
判断要らないとわかるんです
判断入れないと分かったら
判断禁止という必要ないでしょう
はい
それで判断
禁止項目で
ラストのセクション
に進めたいと思います
この今日のテーマは正しい判断する方法
でしょう今判断
禁止っていうところに
修行者は
認識の流れを見る
これ能力ないんだからまず身体の流れを
見る
身体の流れを見てそれから感覚の流れを
チェックして好きできます
それできた人は
感情の流れをチェックする
それもできたら心の流れをチェックする
経典で物の見事に死人受給でこの4つの
ステージを書いてありますこういう風に
やりなさいよ
それ変えられませんそれは科学的な教え
です
で今ラストステージで
認識の流れを
見る
判断は
避けて
停止する
例えば今落ち込み
の心
今ちょっと
興奮の心
今
狭くなっている心今ちょっと
拡大している
今はちょっとね
活発な心
そういう風に
認識の流れを
チェックする
認識の流れチェックする時でも重層
魚で
捕まってみるんですね
重曹業が
認識にバイアスをかぶせることを減って
バイアス機能しないようになる
だから
心を認識する人が
分かるんです
怒りが割り込むとどうなる
嫉妬が割り込むとどうなる
落ち込みが割り込むとどうなる
怠けが悪くてどうなるとかその時気をつけ
て
怠けが割り込んだら
修行を止めるでしょう
判断でしょうそれだけやらない
判断しない
今
怠けが割り込んでいる心ですと
観察して進むん
怠けが入って眠っていけば入っているんだ
から一旦寝てからと言っちゃうとこの人
判断しちゃったんです
一旦寝てそれから
修行しますよ
こういうところ厳しいんですよ
判断しないただ見るだけ
しかし
我々の
判断とは感情が決めるもので
科学的な判断じゃないんです
怒り嫉妬憎しみが判断する
んですこんな
判断
危険でしょう
だから
修行者は自分自身の判断にも
あんまり
執着しない
例えばこの花ってすごい綺麗ですねと私は
きれいと判断している誰かが何だこんな
程度きれいというかっこ悪いね
そろそろ人の判断で別
に私そんなこと言わないでくださいよとか
これだからこれだからこれだからこれだ
から綺麗でしょうとかねあの人責めること
はしません
言っとくか何かとこれちょっとまずいねと
そうですか
自分が食べたらまずくないん
ですだからあんた何考えてる物事食べた
ことないのか
これってすごいなんだん店で買った
なんだらから伝統のある家の店の食べ物
でしょうに家に決まっているでしょうにと
か
ねそんな
くだらない自分の
判断に
執着して
凄い争いの世界を作るんですそうですかで
終わらないんでしょう
だから
有名な店とか伝統的なありますけどね
私は何回も何回もトラの洋館買ったことが
ありましたけどね自分食べれちゃダメじゃ
なくてお土産とってね
だからトラの
羊羹食べたこともありますよそれでこの
洋館こんな感じ普通のスーパーで売って
いる羊羹はこんな味
それだけで
はいそういうことで
この心を観察する
認識を観察する人がこの
判断やめているでしょう
判断やめていても
煩悩が感情が判断決めて正しい判断させ
ないということも分かって
判断
停止しているんですねそこで
初めて
20通に
ありのままに感謝することができるん
です
判断しないで
今できますよ今目を開けてここら辺見たら
壁とも判断しているんです
だからこれは光の速度よりずっとすごく
速いんです皆様この
機械見てスピーカーやと判断するために
どれくらい時間かかる
でもこのデータが溢れて
過去の概念と混ぜてスピーカーという言葉
作るんです
判断選んだんです
瞬間で送るんですだからちょっと
瞑想修行する必要がある
そこで
初めてありのままに
見られるようになるそうすると世の中は
本当にどんな風なことかと目に触れるもの
は何なのか
耳に触れるデータ何なのか
と身体に触れるデータ何なのかとそのまま
見えてくるん
これは仏教用語でダンマは現場になると
言うん
です
頑張っているのは現象の本来の姿
これ幻覚世界ですよ本当
はこのホールは頭の中で作る画像なんです
ホールは目に映りません
そこでダンマということはこの現代用語で
言えば物は存在しない
全て波長です
電磁波です
物質の場合はこの電磁波が心がけて変わっ
ちゃうん
ですだから電磁波なのに
我々はマイクロフォンだ
机だテーブルだと思っているんです
ものですけどソリューションというか
流れてよう
か
量子力学でどちら取ったってもいいんじゃ
ないかという感じで
いるんです
でそのように物は存在しないあるのは
無常なんですいわゆる
波だけなんです
だから面白いんですよ我々にはこの花を見
て花枯れることを見て無常と言えるんだ
けどあれは正しくないん
ですなぜならば私は
じーっといて
花が無常ですということです
自分も同じスピードで変化したということ
は分かってないん
ですそこで二つの物質が同じスピードで
変化すると
この物質にはいつでもあの物質があるん
です
変化しているということは認識できなく
なっちゃうん
です同じ方向で同じスピードで車2つ行く
と止まっているように見えるでしょう
そんな感じ
でだから一般の人々には無常発見できませ
んこの
判断やめて心の流れ観察した人が
判断やめたところで
初めて無料
経験する無常ということは現代単語と言え
ば全て
波長でやって飲み飲み屋とそうする自分も
同じ波でしょう
その大体自分が聞いているんです
よだから無常で区というのはそれ系にある
と思うことによって
ありとあらゆる子が生まれるんだよと苦は
心の感覚です
ね実態はないんだと
物が存在しないんだとそれは無我というん
です
で無常の場合はほとんど物質だけ
中心して言うことで無我というと物質心も
一緒に合わせて
波長で向かう
と
言葉の違うだけで意味は同じですそれ発見
するんです
騙したんです真理は知ったんです
住所
式が自我自分こそという
錯覚をしてきたんですだから自分っての
錯覚です
自我手の錯覚です
子がいるということ錯覚ですこれ発見する
んです自我には
判断することが必要だったこの
判断すること必要な自我があったんだから
ね
錯覚があったんだからなんです
成り立たないということ
でそれで判断の停止ということに行くん
です自我は錯覚であり現象は無常であると
如実に認識すると
判断して生きること自体が
終わらないこの回転であったと
発見する今までこの回転であったと分かる
最後に判断によって一切の判断がなくなる
んでこれ最後の判断します
全て
迎えとすべて
波長で成り立たないんだとその判断で一切
の判断が消え
ます学者は全額良い悪いなどの
判断は一切行わないんですだから
仏教の世界で
瞑想実践で
悟りに達した人々はただ普通に生きている
他の人に
理解できないでも何一つも判断しない
無理をして判断しないことにしましょうで
はないんです
判断はないんですただ判断しないそれだけ
全て終わります
あのねこれすごく美味しいんですあそう
ですか
学者は正しい
判断をする
訓練
判断
能力の
訓練はここで
終了になります
で
途中で
比較的に正しい判断するプログラムを教え
ましたでもそれは最終的な答えじゃないん
です例えば自力者で判断してもそれほど
正しくないということは見えるかもだって
自分の自力者に
合わせるでしょう判断は
まあいい加減中途半端な地域者だったら
判断もいい加減中途半端な問題になるだ
から
判断の場合はいつだってそういうことで
あまり
信頼できない
しかし
間違っているさん判断悪の心
罪の心で
豚人の心でする
判断は悪だからやめるそれから良い心で心
で判断する
それも中途半端であまりよく
それほどということでもあるしそれから
より
判断の流れをチェックして
認識流れをチェックして
判断
成り立たないという
ことに
達する
それでプログラム終わりです
判断能力訓練はここで
終了になりますこれで
順番は
ご飯だまずみんなにあるのはご判断から
より良い判断できる人間になるそこから
正しい
判断できる人間になるそこから
判断次元を超える
という
4つのステージで
完了しますはいありがとうございますそれ
で終わりでしょうか
[拍手]
ありがとうございます
まだしばらくお時間ございますが先生
質疑応答の時間取りたいと思うんですけど
休憩を挟みますか
このままやっちゃいますか
[音楽]
皆様の判断次第
ちょっと休憩入れましょうか
であの10分ぐらい休憩取りたいと思い
ますのでお手洗いなど行かれたい方は
どうぞあとロビーの方で山河新社さんが
書籍の販売やっておりますのでぜひこの
機会に手にとっていただいてよろしければ
ご購入くださいそれでは10分間休憩
いたします
[音楽]
それでは間もなく再開いたします
これからのご質問がある方はいらっしゃい
ましたらまあご挙手いただきましてそれで
マイクを回して
質問いただきたいと思いますがなるべく
簡潔にご質問だけしていただければと思い
ますそれから本日の
講演会の内容はですね今YouTubeで
ライブ配信しておりますのでコミッター
プライバシーに関わることなどはご自分の
判断で
適当にぼかしてお話しくださいよろしくお
願いします
それではご
質問ある方ご教示いただきましたら
係りのものがマイクを回しますでは中段の
方
挙手されている方のところにマイクを回し
てくださいお願いいたします
よろしくお願いします私は
警察が家に入ってきて家の中を壊し
壊していますどうしたらいいですか
[音楽]
警察ですかはい警察ですどういう容疑なん
ですか
いやわかりません
あの冷蔵庫冷蔵を持ってきてるんですか
操作令嬢私がいない時だけ入ってくる
あのそういうことないと思いますけど
ないと思うのはあなたの
誤りで実際は入っています
なんか証拠があるんですよ
一応あります
どうしますか
あの他に何かご質問ある方いらっしゃい
何かあのそれで
損害とか受けたことありますかね
損害受けました
靴を壊されました
シャープペンシルコはシャープペンシルは
買って3日目に壊されました
あといろいろなもの
壊されて
覚えきれません
それはね
[音楽]
攻撃する力がないと向こうは思っている
でしょうね
まあいいや勝手にやってくださいという
態度するしかないん
あはいありがとうございました
[音楽]
はい他に
質問ある方いらっしゃいますか
あの後ろの何の今高く手あげてる方に回し
てください
[音楽]
はいえー2週間前自習
瞑想会の方に参加させていただきましてご
指導いただきました誠にありがとうござい
ましたその時なんですけれども正直
申し上げて私
長老が目の前でぶっ倒れるんじゃないかと
ずっとヒヤヒヤしながらお話し聞いていた
んですけれども今日は
冗談が飛び出るほど非常に調子も良いよう
でこの2週間に一体何があったのかと逆に
そちらの方が気になる有様でございます
なんというかその
健康の秘訣みたいなものが聞けると
ちょっと嬉しいと思いますよろしくお願い
します
あの健康の
健康でいるということは不可能でしょうと
私は思ってますね
あの2週間前は本当に調子が悪そうだった
んですが
悪い時ありますよ
まぁ基本は別に上司がいいかどうかよく
自分でわからないんだけどただ自分
の仕事になると
我を忘れて仕事をする
それでも今日私はちょっと思考がなんか
濁っているなって濁っているなとかね感じ
たりしてね
ちょっと話が
わからなくなっているようなこともある
でしょうとか心配しながら喋っていたん
です
だからすごい体調が良くて健康だったら
この同じテーマでもものすごく
プレゼンテーションが変わります
まあとにかくそれは置いておいて個人的な
ことで
健康でいるということは
判断でねそれって成り立たないんですよ
どうしても物事は衰えていかなくちゃいけ
ないし
だから
健康で何も人々は
過去で
終わった出来事
いわゆる死んだこと
蘇って欲しいと悩んでいるだけ
だから病気になったらいいんで別に
昔はこんなことなかったとかもそれは昔
戻れませんし
ねだから今どうすればいいかという程度で
生きてみればいいんです
私は今ちょっと
歩けない早く
10くらい歩いたっても戦争がすごく
混乱する
すごく
刺激がなくなるような状態になる
ですから大変なではなくて冗談で私はもし
かすると
すぐ死んで倒れるかもしれません
自分に冗談言いながらとにかくそんなこと
になったらまぁハチャメチャ迷惑だからね
丁寧にゆっくり歩きますよと
丁寧にゆっくり歩くんです
健康に戻りたいと思わないんです
病気になりたいと思ってないんです
どうせ身体が毎日毎日衰えるということは
当たり前のことだから心配する必要はない
んです
ねまあ心配したら
衰えることは
なくなるならば大いに心配してあげます
で心配すればするほど苦しいだけ
なんてこうなっているのかとか
ねそういうことで
心配もしないで今の状況はこういう状況で
あるという
程度で
観察で
椅子だって悩んじゃうと損ですね
不平不満思っちゃうと
損です
ね私は悩むことはしない不平不満は思わ
ないとかねでも周りでいろんな変なことを
やっちゃいますからねその時いろんな
冗談でそういうのはこの何て言いますかお
互い
冗談の話に入れ替えちゃうん
です私も人
叱らなくちゃいかんだけで叱りませんその
代わりなんか冗談に行って
とことんからかっちゃう
人も楽しくなっちゃうし同時に言っている
ことを理解するんですこれこれやめたほう
がいいなとか
ねそれは理解する
[音楽]
そういうふうなことでね明るく生きれば
いいでしょう
はい
はい他に質問ある方いらっしゃいます
かはいでは前の方の
段の方
お二人でいらっしゃいますね前の方から先
にはいそれから後ろの方も1方
すいませんちょっと手を挙げといて
いただけますか申し訳ないです
[音楽]
今日は
貴重な話ありがとうございました
地方でお菓子屋さんをやっていてこの
コストアップインフレに
負けないように
コストが上がってるんですが
値段を上げて
利益が出るように
挑戦しています今日の
判断力を聞いてどうにか判断しようかなと
思っていたんですが
判断はしないようにということなのでこの
まま潰れるのを待つのはちょっと嫌だなと
どの程度利上げをしたらいいんでしょう
地方でお菓子屋さんをやってるそうです
それで最近そのコストアップ
インフレインフレーションで
原料費がすごく上がってるのである程度
値上げをしてなんとか商売を続けたいん
ですけどそれでまあそういう判断を迫られ
ているんですけど
先ほどの話で判断しないことという話が
あったので
どうしたらいいでしょうかと
だからこれ誰だって取る手段でしょう
値段上げてあげてあげてとかねでも値段
上げちゃうとどんどん買う不思議なものを
買うことも
減るんですね
だから別ななんかすごい大胆なアイディア
内のかとかね
なんかすごい楽しくこれ真剣に物事を見
ないで世の中どうして変わるもんだからと
かねなんか
楽しい何かできる
じゃないかなとかねそういうこの
値段上げる
材料
値段上がったんだからだけではうまく商売
がないんですよ
じゃあそれにどんな工夫すればいいかどう
か
ね
[音楽]
テレビなんか見ると何と言いますか
このパッケージが変わりましたとかね
新しい
偉い宣伝してよくよく見ると
値段そのままとかねでも中に入っている
あれは
減ってる
値段そのままで
パッケージのあれリサに変わっているとか
そんな風ないろいろなことやってますね
それそういう風にどこまでできるのかと
チェックしてください
だから
どうしてもこれ続かなくちゃと思っても
変わる世界だからね
世界とは対立できないんですね
だから世界の流れをチェックしながらこの
商売っていうのは消費者がいて
作る人がいて成り立つんだからこの
カスタマーの方々の
希望欲望をチェックして
ねそれに合わせて
変化するという
だからそれはこの
こうすればうまく答えますこれはとにかく
もう
赤字を出さないで
商売続けたいということだけではではなく
て
この無常の世界で変化する世界で
自分に何か
挑戦かかっているんですねあんたどうする
そのまま死ぬあるいは続けてやるという
ねだからじゃあ負けるちょっとかっこ悪い
んですねそういうわけでこの
消費者のカスタマーたちの心の変化も
チェックして
こうしたら
まあいいんじゃないかとかね
消費に人気が出てくるんじゃないかとかね
そんな方法で
考えるんですよ
おかしい
こんな商売のこと私あまり具体的なんです
けど
例えばおかしい食べるとねあまりも
我々みたいな人間から体に悪いということ
になるんだけど
おかしい食べて気分爽快になって
元気に頑張ろうとかね
で
意識しなくなっちゃって明るくなり
ましょうという風なコマーシャル
プレイス使ったりとか
ねやっぱりあのお菓子食べたらちょっと
気分いいだよと
そういう風に
[音楽]
人に喜びを売ることでしょう結局は最終的
には
ね品物というよりも
ねそういうことでいかに人に喜び楽しみを
与えるのかという方向へいろいろ考えて
調整してください
ありがとうございます
楽しみながら挑戦します
はいそれでは後ろの段の方でもう一度
ちょっと手あげていただけますか面白かっ
た
質問ある方いらっしゃったかと思います
けどよろしいですか
よろしいですか
他の方
面白かったあの前の段の方お前の方でもう
一方手あげてる方いらっしゃいます
よろしくお願いします
前の列の方
ありがとうございます
よく書店とかで直感力を鍛えるとか直感力
を信じるとかその
判断を直感的に行うっていう本がありまし
ていつもかっこいいなあという風に感じて
しまうんですがその直感直感っていうのも
やはりこの
好みとか嫌いとか怖がってる無知とかから
くるもんなんですかというのとあとその
直感をもやっぱりチェックした方がいいの
でしょうか
そこら辺でちょっとこの一概に何とも言え
ないんだけどいい加減な直感がある場合も
ありますし
なんか直感の方が良かった時もあるんです
ね
で私は
研究したことないで直感で何なのかと
英語の言葉入れて考えちゃうんだから
ちょっと皆様の考えと
合わないところ出てくるかもしれませんね
私は使うのはインスピレーションという
言葉なんですね
インスピレーションと面白いんですよ
あれは楽しいんです
たったアイディアが浮かぶとかね
これ
なかなか良い能力ですだと思いますよ
必ずもこれ正解かどうかわからない
しかし
五分五分より直観の方がうまくいくことが
あります
例えば直感の時も
4つの機器が割り込むとアウトなんです
このインスピレーションだから
インスピレーションというのはちょっと
マンネリで考えないということなんです
それの訓練できます
よ世間に何も言わないで自分一人で
いろんな物事
を何か逆さまに考えたり変なことを何か
おかしいように考えたり
こうなったらどうなるでしょうかとかね
こうなったらどうしようかどうかね
ちょこちょこっと
このマンネリで流れる思考をちょっと
頭の中のゲームなんですね
それ
やってみると結構
直感というものは現れてきます
で私のやり方個人的にやり方は
何でも冗談で笑いっぱなしに変えようと
帰ろう
とだから全部人に言わないんだけど
何でもなんか変な冗談で
ふざけて
真剣な出来事でもなんか
笑い話にする
具体的に理解させるために一つ言います私
の身体の
血管はなかなか見えないん
ですこれで結果も遅いし
いくら
頑張ってもこの手のここら辺の結果見える
んだけど
身体でどこにもいいか見えない今年寄りだ
からもう
定期的に
欠席検査があるんです
その行くたびに私はちょっとこれ
針をさせなかったらねこれ3回4回刺して
失敗して
傷だらけで帰りたくないんです
ある日看護師さんに行ったのあの
結石
が
いたら
先に言わなかったら私は結果持ってきたか
どうか分かりませんよと言ったんです
だから
普段誰も言わない言葉でしょう
結果持ってきたかどうかを
言わなかったんだから言っちゃうとあの人
に何言ってるか分からないんだから手を
触ってみたら分かったんですねやっぱり
欠陥は見つからないということ
そうすると本人が一生懸命頑張って1回で
針を刺したんですそして自慢するんで結果
がありましたよと
だから私が変なところのこと言ったんだ
から
疲れている看護婦さんにもなんか変なこと
言って
瞬間の楽しみが現れたと思います
だから同じ言語は毎回使えないんだから
毎月行きますよ
毎日が新しい考えるんです
今日は何言おうかなとか
で今自分のことを慣れているんだから
あまり言わなくたってよみんなすごい
丁寧に
欠陥を触って触ってただ指先の感覚だけ
でしょう私の場合はあの看護師さんがあれ
ば手袋外すんです
手袋外して指先で
触って触って触って見つけたらそこで止め
てそれから
針を刺すんですだからそこまで私なりに
向こうは進んでもらったんだからねだから
そんな
類の
能力でしょうインスピレーションというの
は
ねだからマンネルで言っちゃうと大体
最低3回はさせます
でそれで何か
貼っちゃうんだからなんか不便気持ち悪い
しね
[音楽]
だからちょっと
違ったことを私の方で
提案する
だからお医者さんも看護婦さんも私が来る
と結構楽しくあるんです
そういうことでこの
それだけでしょう
世界は
膨大だからね生きる環境もいろんな関係
あるんだから
[音楽]
例えば私は料理はもう下手な出来ないん
ですできないんだけど私は何でも何か
ちょこっと食べれば十分それでも自分の家
にもう一人
元気な若者が住んでいるし
あいつは勉強に行ったり学校に行ったり
バイトに行ったりとかねだから店で買って
た食べさせたくはないしだから私は料理
作っておいておくんです
そこで私はこれはもう一回作った料理に
移動できないで私に
また作ると変わる味も全部
だから料理下手って意味でしょう
逆にこれは一回しかこの世の中で現れない
食べ物だからね
今食べなかったらもうあなた
存在しますよと
あと作れませんよ
だから私が下手っている言わなくてもいい
でしょう
ねだからそこでちょっと
新しいアイディアで
雰囲気を作って
問題は解決する
一応
人間食べるものだから人間の体に入れる
ものだから
真剣に作りますよ
いい加減手抜きはそれはないんですなぜ
ならば私はいくら下手であってもこれは
食べて身体に入れるものだから
命を大事にしなくちゃいけない
それだけ気をつけているんだから
何を作ったっても相性食べます大丈夫です
そこで私の分母と残しておいちゃうんだ
けど自分が次の技まあいいや女の子必要
そういうことでこの
ちょっとしたインスピレーションを使って
このインスピレーションとわからない場合
はちょっと
冗談
ギャグ作るという
この
ユーマっていうのは物事をちょっと逆さま
に取ることでしょう
あれで
インスピレーションが現れますよ
このプロの
そういう人々に
プロのこのエリアの方々は
普通の芸能人よりはものすごい頭がいいん
です
やっていることはただのコミュニティです
けど
ね私はいろんな人のコミュニティを見て
ネットでもいくらでもあります
からコーデに笑うよりは
不思議に思うのこいつのこの
研究の能力
観察
能力すごいもんだなあと
なんかいいということを出してくれるん
ですある人が
インド人のところでコメディアやりながら
いきなり
インド人であなた方とメキシコ人がね同じ
でしょう
どういう風に言っちゃって次に言うのは
インド人が
ケンタという
砂糖の飲み物ありますね
インドどこ行っても
子供でもハンター用飲むと
メキシコ人もどこ行ったってもコーラでも
何でもなくパンダでしょうとだからあなた
同じだ
[音楽]
とだから明らかにインド人と同じじゃない
んです
これ無理やり同じにする
いろんな方法でからかっちゃうんですね
まぁ本人がもうアメリカどこかでやってる
コメディアンですけど
やっぱり
インスピレーションするんですよ
くだらないでしょう取り上げちゃってこれ
えらい真剣真面目に出しちゃって
だから
慢性の嘘ではないんですインドに近い
スリランカにしたってもなんか若者は
ファンタ飲んでいるような気がします
私は両方も飲めませんだけど
子供達とかねあんたは喜んで飲んでいる
こと見ているそれだったらインド人も同じ
でしょうと
まぁメキシコ人も頼んでいるんだったら
しょうがないみんな同じ
そんな感じでねだからあのこういう
コメディアンたちの話見ると私驚くのそう
いう人々は
くだらない何のこともないところから
データを取ってすごい
[音楽]
コミュニティーなストーリーを作っちゃう
すごいですよもう中国人だから中国人バカ
にするための笑うための小麦だったら英語
のイントネーションが変わっちゃうんです
ね
インド人のことばかりして笑っちゃうんだ
インドネシアの変わっちゃうんです
のことを言ってばかりでしょうに変わっ
ちゃう
です
すごい能力でしょうに
だから今
ネットありますからねまぁいろんな国々の
この優秀なね人々の
能力を見るし私はこれインスピレーション
というね直感アイディアが浮かぶことね
すごく人間にとって面白いとは思いますよ
で直感的に物事を考えることが面白い能力
ですそれが役に立つか立たないかまた別な
話でどんな直感でもうまくいくわけじゃ
ないんです
時々直感で分かっても
言わない方がいい時もあります
悪い能力ではなくてすごく良い能力なん
ですね
それはね使用書く人々の必要し
絵を描く人々に画家でも必要でしょうし
音楽家にも必要でしょうし
これ料理のやってる人々にもあった方が
いいでしょうで新しい料理考えられます
から
ねある日これはテレビで見たんだけど
この田舎で
普通日本の伝統的な
野菜やらいろんなものイタリア料理作る人
なんですね日本の伝統的な
野菜はイタリア料理フランス料理に作ると
いうことは
ねちょっと難しい
この人これ
生で食べてみるんです
ねそれと食材見るたび何でも生で食べて
みる
あの瞬間だこれはこんなこんなプロセスで
作ればOKだと
言って
抜群に作ってみせるん
です全く
伝統的に日本で田舎でしか食べられない
ものなんですけどこれは西洋の食卓で
びっくりするように
料理作ってなすったりとかねだからそれっ
てインスピレーション直感でしょうどこか
で訓練したものじゃないでしょう自分が
自分の
チェストをしてその分で
伝統的な訓練を受けているでもそれだっ
たら超つまらないんですよ
フランスで学んだ料理だけ作ってお客様に
出す
つまらないん
です売れないん
ですフランス料理はとことん学んでメダル
も取って
権限を取って帰っても日本の
豆腐やら味噌やら使ってフランス料理作っ
ちゃえばすごいアイデアでしょう
だから
わかめでも何でもいいんですフランス料理
に
わかめ使っているとかねだからその人々は
ただ単に日本で使うような若味入れちゃう
とアウト
合わない
それは魚のなんとか料理作でその周りに
何か美しくかっこよく
若く入れて
どうですか
とそういうちょっとのところでこの
インスピレーションが働くんですねだから
すごい大事な能力だと思います
だから物事すごい真剣に神経
質で
ガリガリって感じでね
見ないで
軽く楽しく
思考を泣かせるとインスピレーションが
出てくると思います
ねはい以上ですありがとうございました
はいそれではちょうど時間になりましたの
で
質疑応答の時間これで終了したいと思い
ます最後に
[音楽]
はいでは最後のこの祈願の
原因となりましょうご一緒に
[音楽]
かほんと
サンリオピバーニの
苦しんで
悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が
恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が
悲しみもなく一歳の生命が安穏であります
ように
サルサル
はいどうもありがとうございます
[拍手]
皆様長時間にわたりご清聴ありがとう
ございました
本日の
午後8時からですね
今日の
講演会の振り返りのズームの
ズームミーティングございますよろしけれ
ばそちらにもご参加ください初期
仏教月例講演会しばらく間が空きますが
次回は12月の9日に日暮里サニーホール
で開催いたしますまた近くなりましたら
教会のホームページ等でご案内すると思い
ますのでまたお誘い合わせの上ご来場
いただければと思いますそれから
携帯電話などのお忘れ物が結構
ある場合ございますので
席の間に入っちゃったりしてる場合もあり
ますのでもう一度
身の回りをご確認の上でお帰りいただけれ
ばと思いますそれでは今日もどうも
ありがとうございました
[拍手]
はいありがとうございましたあのお寺に
一度来てですねボランティアしてみたいと
かお坊様にお食事のお布施をしてみたいと
かなんかそういったことに関心がある方
ちょっと残っていただけたらあの会員の方
が会員のものがご案内しますのでどうぞ
はいあのね東京の会員の方多いんですけど
まだねお食事の布施したことがない方も
いらっしゃってとっても楽しいのでぜひと
思っておりますはい
では自由の瞑想いたします
私は
幸せでありますように
私の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますよう
に私の
[音楽]
願い事が
叶えられますように
[音楽]
私に
悟りの光が
現れますように
私は
幸せでありますように
幸せであります
よこれから私は
幸せでありますようにと心の中で
繰り返し
念じてください
私の
生命が
幸せでありますよう
私の
親しい生命の
悩み
苦しみが
なくなるますように
私の
親しい
生命の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私の
親しい
生命に
も
悟りの
怒りが
現れますよう
私の親しい
生命が
幸せでありますように
私の親しい
生命が
幸せでありますように
私の
生命が
幸せでありますように
はいこれから親しい生命が
幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し
念じます
続けるものが
幸せでありますように
生きたし行けるものの
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
いけるものの
願い事が
叶えられますように
行けるものにも
悟り